foreign
[Music]
IBM was a household name they were the
most well-known computer manufacturer in
the world period but today while people
still recognize the name virtually no
one buys a computer from IBM in fact you
can't even buy an IBM computer even if
you wanted given that they sold a
business to Lenovo nearly 20 years ago
this is quite surprising given that by
all accounts IBM was very much a first
mover within the PC industry they
launched their first consumer PC way
back in 1981 and I mean the company's
name itself is an international business
machine yet by the late 1980s IBM was
rapidly losing market share to newcomers
like Dell and Compaq heck even the
operating system that they had funded
had turned into Microsoft this downtrend
only got worse in the 1990s as IBM would
go on to post the worst quarter in
corporate history having lost 4.96
billion dollars IBM's market cap would
have in value while the S P 500 nearly
doubled fortunately for IBM the.com
bubble would give them some room to
breathe as investors were lenient to say
the least but as the.com bubble
collapsed in their early 2000s Focus
shifted back to IBM's underperformance
within the PC market and this eventually
led to IBM offloading their most
recognizable business considering the
situation you would think that IBM was
headed towards bankruptcy or at the very
least a painful decline but the exact
opposite would actually take place IBM's
Revenue earnings and market cap were to
all Skyrocket and IBM would even
overtake Microsoft for a couple of years
until Microsoft had their own Resurgence
and today IBM stands at a market cap of
133 billion dollars which makes them the
world's 90th largest company clearly
losing within the PC industry hasn't
killed off IBM altogether so here's the
rise of fall and resurrection of one of
the most iconic brands of all time
taking a look back the roots of IBM
actually date back to the 1800s to four
different companies which included the
abundee manufacturing company the
tabulating Machine Company the
international time recording company and
the Computing Scale Company of America
by far the most important of these was
the tabulating machine company this
company focused on creating a data
processing machines for Punch Cards this
proved to be relatively successful given
that it was a must-have at manufacturing
plants and factories but the problem was
that revenue from this business was
sporadic and unreliable I mean how many
times our prominent Factory is going to
need to buy punch card machines maybe
once a few years if that so the founder
of the company Hermann hollowrid would
shift the focus to a larger project than
1900 census the census challenged his
machines like it never before due to the
raw volume and scale but Herman would
successfully complete the project which
gave him some notoriety within the
industry despite this though it didn't
take him long to fall back to Ground
Zero you see it the U.S only conducts
its senses once every 10 years so
Revenue became sporadic and unreliable
once again while her men very much
wanted to turn this around he was
getting into his 50s and his health
wasn't quite holding up so he decided to
sell the company to a man named Charles
Flint for 2.3 million dollars Flint
would combine this with a few other
businesses and to create a new company
called CTR and very quickly it became
obvious that Flint was no rookie at
business he didn't change anything
technical about the company instead it
he simply focused on expanding the use
cases and the Salesforce he would hire
an executive named Thomas J Watson and
Watson would basically become the father
of IBM the first thing that Watson did
was hire a bunch of salesmen and teach
them the intricacies of Enterprise sales
he instilled the values of company Pride
unbeatable customer service and
professionalism Watson also expanded the
scope of the company from just selling
punch card machines to providing
corporations with a large-scale type
Landing Solutions this turned out to be
extremely successful and Watson would
end up doubling the company's Revenue
within just four years of taking over
very soon CTR would begin expanding it
internationally into Europe South
America Asia and Australia Watson would
also hone in on the company's branding
and a Public Image one of his first
branding efforts was creating a company
slogan and for this he would just reuse
a slogan that he thought of at his last
job think you might recognize this
slogan today with the Lenovo ThinkPad
anyway Watson now had a company slogan
but there was still something that was
really irking him Watson hated the name
CTR he felt that it was clunky and
confining so in 1924 he would change the
name of the company to IBM or
international business machine it seems
like this name change it may have been a
bit unlucky though as the Great
Depression would roll around it not much
later
the Great Depression would hit IBM hard
given that businesses were collapsing
left and right and given that IBM was a
B2B business they had an extremely tough
time keeping clients nonetheless Watson
didn't Panic he was a strong believer in
the idea that if he had a great team
knows building useful products demand
would follow Watson wouldn't not only
hire more employees during the Great
Depression but he would even increase
their benefits IBM was one of the first
companies to provide a group life
insurance survivor benefits and to paid
vacations but despite Watson's positive
approach the effects of the Great
Depression were very much evident
throughout IBM IBM was building up a
massive inventory of tabulini equipment
with no Market to sell to but as Watson
was hoping an opportunity would
eventually arise and it was massive in
1935 FDR would sign into effect the
Social Security Act which required
tabulating employment records for 26
million people IBM was the only company
that bid on this contract and by the end
of the depression IBM would evolve from
being a mid-sized company to being an
industry leader their dominance would
only grow with the onset of World War II
as IBM's tablet equipment would prove
instrumental in the war the Allied
Forces widely used IBM's equipment for
mobile record units ballistics
accounting Logistics and of course Punch
Cards to keep up with all this demand
IBM would grow their manufacturing
capacity exponentially opening factories
all across the Northeast and California
despite all this growth Watson had a
fear in the back of his mind what would
happen when the war came to an end and
government spending was cut
substantially Watson began addressing
this issue early on to prepare as much
as possible he increased IBM's
International presence and played a
major role in the formation of the World
Trade Corporation but it turned out that
none of this preparation was even
required as soon as World War II came to
an end the us would get knees deep into
the a Cold War the government no longer
needed typing equipment per se though
what they wanted was a highly
intelligent machiner also known as a
computer and that this is what got IBM
into the PC game unfortunately Watson
never got to see this Evolution as he
would pass away in 1956 but he very much
laid the foundation for IBM's pivot into
the PC market just one year after Watson
passed away IBM would introduce the
programming language Fortran IPM would
follow this up with the slew of
computers such as the IBM 1401 and the
IBM 1403 but the Breakthrough didn't
happen until 1964 when they introduced
the IBM system 360. the feature that set
apart this computer was the fact that
the hardware and software were no longer
bundled in other words you could upgrade
it and swap software this proved to be
instrumental for NASA and the NASA would
end up using IBM's computers to land the
first humans on the moon in 1969. this
was no doubt the golden age for IBM but
Watson's appears from 25 years ago would
start coming to fruition after winning
the Space Race the government would
heavily pull back on spending
[Music]
while the government pulled back their
contracts IBM was by no means in any
distress over the past 30 years IBM had
to build an international brand and had
a major companies as clients so they
were by no means going to die but given
that they had maxed out on the corporate
and government side of things IBM was
forced to look for new ways to grow it
and that this led them to the public
sector the only problem was that IBM had
virtually no experience selling to
Everyday consumers and it would show IBM
didn't know it at the time though and
they would launch projects camp in 1973.
this project is what would eventually
lead to the introduction of IBM's first
personal computer in 1981 to IBM 5150
this computer actually turned out to be
a massive success because it made PCS
relatively affordable For the First Time
The 5150 launched for a price of sixteen
hundred dollars and while that was by no
means cheap as it translates to 5200 it
was way cheaper than everything else on
the market the Xerox star for example
came in at an eye-watering 16 500
meanwhile the Apple Macintosh came in at
2 500 so for Budget oriented customers
which is most customers the 5150 was the
Top Choice this would allow for IBM to
dominate the market throughout the early
1980s but there was one major problem
people weren't buying IBM computers
because there was some sort of unique
feature to them or because people love
the brand brother much of IBM's
popularity could be explained by their
price and that this is never a good
thing as it almost always leads to a
race to the bottom and that's exactly
what happened dozens of new computer
manufacturers like Dell popped up but
there was one key difference between
manufacturers like IBM and manufacturers
like Dell the difference was that
companies like Dell weren't computer
manufacturers at all there were computer
assemblers they didn't create new
architectures or put together software
or any of that they sent simply Source
the cheapest Parts on the market install
the MS-DOS and it called it a day this
allowed them to undercut IBM by
significant margins the Dell turbo for
example costed a mere 795 dollars which
was half of IBM and given that IBM
hadn't built any brand loyalty people
switched to these counterparts in a
heartbeat and the harsh reality was that
IBM simply couldn't not compete at these
prices they simply had a far more
overhead and r d expenses IBM didn't
want to call it quits though so they
just stuck around as their PC market
share when the year after year after
year and it wasn't until after the.com
bubble that they would finally decide to
pull the plugin and sell their PC
business to Lenovo and that marked the
end of IBM's foray into consumer
products
foreign
had gotten destroyed in the consumer PC
market the commercial business was still
doing all right so they decided to
double down on Commercial customers and
that this led them to a new Gold Mine
which was servers databases and of
course cloud computing pretty soon IBM
was starting to turn things around and
it seemed like IBM was very much
resurrected but it wasn't all sunshines
and rainbows because their freedom
within the cloud Market it didn't last
all that long since then basically every
company Under the Sun has jumped onto
the market whether it be apple Google
Della oracola or Microsoft they all want
a piece of the pie and this has led to
IBM shedding much of its Cloud gains in
fact IBM is very much in a downtrend
once again in the past 10 years IBM's
Revenue hasn't nearly halved from over a
hundred billion dollars to barely 60
billion dollars a similar story can be
seen with their net income as well which
just shrunk from over 15 billion dollars
to just 1.2 billion dollars it seems
like investors are still giving IBM a
good amount of credit as they've been
able to maintain a p e ratio of over a
hundred but if IBM continues to put up
lackluster performance then it's not
clear how much longer investors will
give them leeway but that's just what I
think do you think IBM has a future
comment that down below also drop a like
if you're grateful for IBM's
contributions and of course consider
checking out our Discord Community it
suggests for the video ideas and to
consider subscribing to see more
questions also answered until then I'm
Hari and I'll see you guys on the next
one
foreign